[Music]
good morning Millennials who were off
yeah you just took you know I had to
give it a little extra as we say in the
showbiz industry little pizzazz
yeah for just some random Thursday I'm
feeling tired as hell I'm feeling good
as hell I'm actually not but if it in
the moment you know I can't complain
about this because just the four days
has been everything to me it's like I
have no clue what data is and then when
I like to take a guess it's actually the
next day you know and then so all you
have to know about today is that
tomorrow's Friday that's like the most
important thing someone needs to know
about this particular Thursday yeah I
think Thursday's are great days too
because Friday it's like it's already
here and then the weekends gone but
Thursday you just have the anticipation
of the weekend no Jackie Thursday it's
like filled with hope that like that
gets you through yeah and I'm like the
type of person it's like I don't want
the thing to be happening because then
it's over I like having things to look
forward to be excited I'm really a
Thursday kind of girl wow you should
write a song about that there is that
song it's Friday I'm in love you should
just change it it's Thursday
I'm in love it should be on song let me
take just watch last night and they just
can't get over how it's that I show up
sunlight is an amazing show like amazing
premise amazing talent amazing songs
amazing production amazing songwriters
Ryan Tedder Shane McAnally like it's
just it's all good and I always try and
think of who my favorite judges and I
actually love them all equally I can
make the argument for any of them being
my favorite choice like I really don't
know same but mine's Ryan Tedder really
I feel like actually if gun to my head I
had to pick like Ryan Tedder might be
mine so just like 1% because I think if
I had to you know this is a real
dangerous choice
speaking of will recap your house it's
impossible to watch your house is full
of dangerous choices like does she sell
the company right or does she continue
to lose money does she meant her
friendship with LeAnn or Harbor that
resentment it's a true dangerous choice
and by the way I literally every time
they say her name on the show like why
are they saying that like it's like I
own that name now as
choice and she's a lot of choices to
make and we'll get it we'll get into
them later as one does um I think it
might be ester dean for me I just love
her personality and she's so talented
but then I'm like patching precious
Gemma thread and then I'm like Brian
hitmaker so cool Jonas Brothers
OneRepublic what do I do like I was
playing native I live I know last night
it sounds like such a fun night yeah
what else were you doing counselor that
you went out with your friends huh did a
good time yeah what time do you get home
like 10:00 no double digits it was just
like dinner drinks would you where'd you
go for dinner what you eat handcraft
cocktail and kitchen I had a a
watermelon salad you were always going
to like weird new restaurants like you
go to places that I've lived in the city
for a long time and I've literally never
even heard of well I also go to places
in my area do you only mean there's not
that many and there's also so many
restaurants but just ones I've never
heard of so I like may as well just go
to them yeah yeah that's cool like
you're living like the young do pro life
the young professional yeah young kid
the yo Pro mhm life yo Pro Murray Hill
yeah she's all about the hill okay call
it Margo's Hill oh yeah
anyways other than that what did we do
yesterday so that's just long it was the
longest passing four hours yesterday oh
my god I forgot we recorded this natural
guesser that feels like a month ago we
did two and a half hours of podcasting
yesterday because yesterday's show was
ninety minutes then we took it to the
Snatcher where we talked to all about
bachelor in paradise
you haven't listened yet check out the
snatcher on iTunes she's premium as hell
she's starting beef on Instagram was
showing the cast mate I didn't even know
though I thought it was fact that there
was beef I didn't know that I was
starting anything but you know what I'm
always happy when christina is being
taken down um so listen to the snatcher
episode if you care about it it's on
Spotify it's on iTunes it's premium as
hell but I feel like we've had two
guests in a row like we never do that
and now it's like that first hit me how
ourselves like let's talk [ __ ] about the
guests Oh totally who do we have County
and
oh I mean two great girls it was so nice
meeting Kathy like I know
so like such a hard worker so like oh
she's a definition of a hustler she's
like talented she holds her crack humble
but she's hilarious like self like a
confident woman yeah I think that as a
woman like I respect the hell out of her
and as a host like I really look up to
her I couldn't agree more I just was
like so she's the type of person where
it's like her personality like
captivates the room you know what I mean
like everyone knows that Kelsey's in the
room because people just like I feel
like she draws people and was like her
warmth and her humor yeah and I feel as
though like that lady gang of girls like
their um that lady get their dynamic
like makes like a lot of sense and
they're just like super cool women yeah
who are doing doing the damn thing I
[ __ ] hate that liner easy too but it
felt like the only the only phrase for
the job and then tomorrow we have Becca
Tobin who is the coolest person alive
I'm not sure I'm not okay
oh we also need to talk to Becca
gentleman about the fact that like maybe
five years ago be a dinner with her like
a dish you remember she definitely
remember yeah I think we collectively
cringed yeah we could create news like
this we're like so it's a sunglass
company right it was like an influencer
dinner before that was a thing right so
it was like very informal so it was just
like random people and like dinner still
on the air and like I was not okay
personally not okay you know and like I
just there's so many things I want to
talk to her about because it's all the
stuff I wanted to talk to Kelsey about
like podcasting People's Choice Awards
like all the podcast drama but then
there's another layer of like the Glee
drama like when Jenna Ushkowitz and
Kevin McHale we're here like I don't
know it's like I had tomorrow's episodes
gonna have to be six hours long no
totally plus like she's also in hallmark
movies oh right like she's so
multifaceted she really is also I got
such an exciting message I've been asked
to be on the official hallmark podcast
what what do you tell anybody because
it's just like DM and then it's gonna
like you know get it's the hallmark
podcast like discussing babies called um
bubbly bubbly sesh cute yeah they're
like recap movies they have some of the
actors directors like marketing people I
know you that isn't one step of you
getting into a hallmark movie yeah I
know
like it's like round media oh my god
Jess you crying what are you doing it
I don't know we're gonna set it up but
they do it in New York so hopefully soon
but I kinda want to wait until Christmas
is in full swing so I like to have
movies to talk about yeah you know that
is such an accomplishment like I'm so
incredi know that was a dream of fine
you know I didn't even know they had
podcasts my dreams coming true good on
them for tapping into you know local
podcast resources like the number one
the morning show hosts in America
thousand percent Canada what's your
favorite homework movie like what are
you gonna talk what is your favorite I
was thinking about that and I think it
might be miss Christmas I know but it's
also just cuz it's a great one and she's
a great girl
and she's the most beautiful you know a
- what freshman father that's a
Christmas movie oh but it's a hallmark
movie I think it is yes it is it was
lifetime no 8 - hallmark movie I swear
my life freshman father is very like
original a hallmark original I swear and
that's why with that's like so shocking
because it's such a good movie I'm
looking at a freshman father but I'm
telling you why I have to go into my
Hallmark Arsenal and right you gotta do
some research call Barbie Channel told
you wow that is a good one too
you should do a recap of that movie like
and that would never dream
interpretation of it this is a freshman
but he's also a father now he's gave me
both the mom is like a deadbeat mom
situation yeah it's really it's and
space up a true story and it's like he
just wants to keep doing right by
everyone I'm like dare go to Harvard and
it's like where do they make men like
this yeah right who want to go to
Harvard be a single dad and like also a
good son and like gonna take like their
baby mama to Harvard with them right and
like put them all like she doesn't want
to work and like she's like complaining
about holding the laundry oh my god
she's like such a [ __ ] angry she
really was I think she can contribute at
all it's a really good movie let's not
spoil it it's called freshmen father and
like you'll be shocked that it's a
Lifetime movie because like Lifetime
movies are good hard sorry hallmark
they're good for like when you're laying
in bed but I would have seen this movie
in theatres it's like that's how yeah it
was yeah it was it was really good I've
been to the theater in quite a long time
know when there are so many things I
want is I gotta see good boys
I got a boy's hustlers um Lion King I
just took like the kind of time in Halle
I took a big break from the movies I got
NC Lion King Aladdin once upon a time in
Hollywood I feel like there was a surge
of popular movies coming out in the last
like six months and I just like breathe
right by it and didn't see any of them I
just didn't have like the
time to go to the movies or like I just
don't want to sit in the movie you know
I feel like I'm a busy woman even though
like summer is the best time to sit in
the movie cuz it's like one of their few
public places that has air-conditioning
or you could just stay home and watch a
movie that's sure actually don't have a
movies today I got a busy day is there
anything else that makes you feel like a
[ __ ] lazy piece of [ __ ] like
unemployed then go to it would be
starting today no nothing I don't think
that connection you're sitting around
with your fellow unemployed people
catching a flake it's too sad earlier in
the day yeah the matinee yeah it's too
sad let's not do it totes what about
tonight like sushi and a movie I'm busy
Lizzy oh okay sorry snatch are you going
to a concert tonight what are you guys
busy doing with friends yeah no I'm
going away for the weekend tomorrow say
like spray tan and all that [ __ ] okay
that's all to get a spray tan like I
can't go anywhere that's fair I just
want to put it out into the ether Margot
I find it like extremely rude in [ __ ]
up that you're like always hanging out
with your friends like you are my friend
I mean I agree anytime Mother's I'm
where my friends it's always like you
like then I'm telling one friend you're
hanging out with your friends but not
inviting the other for I know but it's
not cuz I don't want to be invited it
just like upsets me that you have like
friends do you know what I think I feel
like if I didn't have rented be really
really concerned I'm like you guys are
my friends like I have friends but like
you guys are my friends like you
shouldn't have any friends except for us
yeah it would make me feel a lot safer
if you just cut them yeah trim the fat
and only hung out with us and now what
movies today while we're on the subject
I also don't like that you have a
roommate
oh yeah well we'll just put any things
out you've been a really [ __ ] rude no
giving but like if I lived alone the bed
would be sad I know I agree and if you
didn't have friends would be sad and
we're just like we just want all of your
time that's true and it's like any time
I just I can't spend the house and I
feel like when she does things with like
other people outside the family is that
weird I I know how you feel because I'm
in your same spot but like we just have
to let her fly okay if you love
something set it free and it loves you
back it'll come it'll come back is that
the phrasing if you love something set
it free and if it's meant to be no and
if it if it ever loved you it'll come
back whatever well I feel as though
we've sufficiently wasted enough time
before diving into the vows five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your mole
in toast I feel like we've fallen into a
routine where like you say that yeah I
haven't said it hold on pass me the
phone
because I would probably give it that
size I do so for everybody no stop I
know it's time I know I know but I would
feel remiss devastated heartbroken so so
truly why I didn't tell you that today's
episode is brought to you by article oh
well you know what that makes me very
happy because furniture shopping is
famously terrible torture salespeople
poor quality pieces interminable shopped
shipping periods the words that's that's
true do you know what took me 14 weeks
there the couch that's [ __ ] crazy
that is the worst part that's my article
decides to change the way that people
shop for furniture instead of schlepping
to a warehouse to shop for particle
board articles online catalog features
high quality pieces that you can browse
right at home
articles team and designers have an eye
to today's trends but focus on timeless
design and great quality I've actually
been on article last night because I'm
looking I'm ready for like phase two of
my furniture
you know spruce up a few things like get
things that look right like always when
you move in like you do the major
furniture and then it's like six months
later you got to spruce it up with like
Ottomans and [ __ ] it's like okay now we
can get rid of the things we've been
carrying around since Saks bachelor
apartment and I'm ready to hit article
because that's the easiest way to make
your space look beautiful they're able
to keep their prices low by cutting out
the middleman and selling directly to
you know showrooms no salespeople no
retail markups articles team of
designers focus on beautifully crafted
pieces quality of material and excellent
construction dedicated to a modern
aesthetic with Scandinavian touches I
have it like these two furry Ottomans
like I just got like aesthetically and
they've truly become like a staple I
feel like I'm in Scandinavia they have a
30-day return policy with simple returns
and exchanges all in stock items are
delivered in less in two weeks or less
that's amazing that is amazing you know
what that was pretty good but not as
good as when I do it but I haven't told
you the best part what's this heart jack
article is offering our listeners $50
off their first purchase or $100 or more
to claim visit article dot-com slash
toasts and the discount code will be
automatically applied at check out
that's article dot-com slash toast to
get $50 off your first purchase of $100
or more this is actually a great company
and one I only know about since
sponsoring the toast and I feel as
though it's great for like that
post-grad apartment when you want it to
be cute but you don't got the big bucks
and you're
living with your roommates and you're
not hanging out with your sisters yeah
it's perfect for that kind of girl I
really have there's so many things I
have to get and I just have a form
article I know just okay it's off your
order of a hundred dollars more and when
you're ordering furniture it's probably
gonna be more than yeah
did you order in furniture successfully
anyways now that we've gotten that out
of the way I feel better excuse me
excuse me
it's better to let it better in than out
I always say wow no better out than in
better in than out no is that from Shrek
yeah but are out than in I always say I
think it's better than I am it over bad
even a swamp
I did I had a flood and now my entire
force when I live in a swamp in Islam I
have many layers yeah and Theo is donkey
dunk it and I'm constantly picking my
ears to wax great and Benes Fiona for
sure for sure but he's only Fiona after
seven you know Brad Pitt reveals he went
to AAA after Angelina Jolie slit Brad
Pitt caught himself out of a dark time
by attending Alcoholics Anonymous
after his highly publicized split from
Angelina Jolie the actor whose ad astra
film is hitting theaters on September
20th told the New York Times said he
attended a a meetings to come out a
drinking problem that was said to have
contributed to the downfall of our
marriage you remember he was on the
plane and was saying he was drunk and I
got a kid oh I don't remember that but
yes yes yes yes quote you had all these
men sitting around being open and honest
in a way I had never heard it was the
space P it was this safe space where
there was little judgment and therefore
little judgment of yourself it was
actually really freeing just to expose
the ugly sides of yourself there's great
value in that the 55 year old actor said
he attended a a meetings for a year and
a half in terms of the extent of his
past drinking he said I'd taken things
as far as I could take it so I removed
my drinking privileges Wow very interest
and I feel like Brad Pitt is very
private and if he was struggling with
sobriety or anything like he definitely
wouldn't have told his fans or the New
York Times so I wonder what this means
like Brad Pitt just like being open you
know yeah also I don't think he really
has a vessel in which to speak to his
hands like he doesn't Twitter to them in
Syria I'm like I doubt he even has a
publicist like that really that you know
is reaching out to him um my very little
out yeah we could hear ourselves on your
yeah yeah um actually I think he does
have a publicist just like formerly like
if anything were to ever happen like you
should always have a publicist I don't
think they're actively like pitching him
for The Tonight Show writing out press
releases pretend a couple the morning
toast unfortunately too bad for us so I
feel as though when he has a new movie
coming out if you talk to someone then
he catches us up on what's been going on
in his life since the last time we heard
from him raised when he was drunk on a
plane yelling at his kid right I like
that whole messy divorce I feel like we
really haven't heard from him nor
Angelina in a really long time yeah and
I think that was for the best because it
was getting a little messy a little
public and they are like so ælis and
this would be like if Prince Harry was
drunk kind of playing yelling at his kid
George in a mall yeah like we we don't
need like it's very acceptable from them
no I agree so I'm glad that they like
zip their [ __ ] up and got us together um
and now he's coming clean with his
sobriety I think that's wonderful yeah I
think it's wonderful too you know it's
it's tough out there I know he's just
like I feel like he's like the whatever
new reference like a movie star like
you'll say Brad Pitt you know like
celebrity crush grab head even though
like he's 50 now but people of all ages
would say he was their celebrity crush
me he's really like this like phenomenon
you know like he's been around for so
long literally everyone loves him he's
never been canceled like knock on wood
you know yeah who knows he's just like a
P John he really is that he was saying
in an other interview recently that like
he's wants to get more into directing
because like acting is a young man's
game so it's like a brad pitt feels like
aged out of Hollywood right where's the
hope for any of them great as a man and
it's like the hottest man alive and
lauded by everyone I'm the best actor
life also I think he's like the best
person ever do you based on like the
bits and pieces I've collected over the
years mostly from ultros portrayal of
him I think he's a great guy I like so
what's his problem I guess you know he
was drinking too much right what do you
mean what's his problem I feel like he's
literally like everyone had no I'm sorry
I didn't mean it like that
everyone has something and that's wrong
with them yeah and what is what what's
wrong with him what's his problem
what's his cross to bear I got it I
meant not drinking yeah that's I didn't
mean like that was a long I got I got my
canteen
I got I got it anyways I want the best
for him I need
once upon a time in Hollywood what in
your opinion is a best Brad Pitt movie
ooh hold on I need to like look yes what
does that come to mind for me are like
Moneyball glorious bastards over stories
but engine but oh my god it's actually
really but a so on I know I don't I
don't know how it is to lose in a movie
called snatch watch me yep so I think
Moneyball and inglorious basterds and
what was the third one I said Benjamin
Button yes sir today I'm sharing this is
a Smith that scene where they're like
beating the [ __ ] out of each other and
like they ruin everything in the house
and then they have sex I was like the
best scene ever
how could they not get married and have
800 kids after that you know yeah Oh a
hundred percent I'm looking at all of
his his work credits he's been a
producer in a lot of films like Eat Pray
Love who knows things like his
production company uh was he in the big
short or he just was a producer um I
don't know I watch it on a plane and the
TV was so small and fuzzy on the plane I
got like so dizzy and I had to stop
watching it but I'm pretty sure he made
a movie called the counselor what's me
are you serious I know I'm looking it up
on my video on Google Brad Pitt movies
week that's insane Margo has he been
like mirroring your life in art I've
been here yeah they say that life
mirrors art oh no art mirrors life so
that's what Brad Pitt has been doing his
in territory or watching you yeah
honestly I can't I feel like there's a
movie that I saw recently that I loved
him in what does he even Oscar for he's
just such a talent you know he I don't
think they'll ever come a time where
like I wouldn't run away with Brad Pitt
you know in the best picture 12 years of
slave that's all he's got yes he was a
producer on 12 years of slave he does
have a movie called snatch Oh
Ocean's eleven is what I just watched I
never watched the oceans franchise I
mean I lived it in Vegas sir after
reading is what I just watched remember
when I said I did something there and I
watched two good movies recent
yeah one of them was burned after eating
which the Coen brothers oh cool and Brad
Pitt was in it and that's why I was
thinking like this is an interesting
part for him to take I like him I wonder
if this is where he got his ears parsed
Oh first sure it's where he got his ears
parsed well wishing the best - Brad Pitt
on his journey to sobriety I've heard it
ain't easy but you know stick with good
people and I feel like you could do it
when Brad okay also like I'm ready for
his next relationship I know it's been
like a good amount of time I feel like
he didn't have any time between Angelina
and Jen so like he never got to live his
like wild crazy single years so maybe
that's what he's doing now before
settling down again maybe I don't know
it like I will on him in Margot Robbie I
want him in Margot wash right oh for
sure no but Margot Robbie is married and
what I'd like about her is that she
doesn't use like her womanhood or like
her relationship status to rice her star
like she just has gotten so famous by
being talented beautiful and like a
class act you know mm-hmm so okay I'm
happy for her and in that particular
scenario even I would love to see them
together agree okay next story bit to
the drama as a follow-up to a story this
week we're at forever 21 he's being sued
by ariana grande for using her likeness
a trillion dollars but now RuPaul's Drag
Race star pheromone accuses ariana
grande of quote stealing from queer
artists so pheromone posted a tweet a
side-by-side of Ariana and seven rings
video and a picture of herself and she
said ariana should give me a cut of that
ten million since her team literally
sent a pic of me to the designer and
paid them to copy my look from as4
parentheses finally met the designer and
got the tea
I guess stealing from queer our artists
for profit is fine though okay so in
this photo it's basically they're both
wearing the same silver bodysuit and now
we know that Ari designer that Farrah
was wearing and asked for like a replica
so it was the one that the Farrah is
wearing made by that artist yes made by
that designer are you sure that's what
it sounds like otherwise well because if
if they're made by the same designer
then that's not copying at all that's
like you're buying the same shirt from
Zara you know yeah they're if Ariana
contacted a designer to copy a look that
this person made that is a case for daya
Prada
yeah you know what I mean the pheromone
said doesn't the fault here lie with the
designer knowingly and willingly being
paid to copy your look so maybe it's not
the same designer I don't think it is
and I thought it was and now this story
seems more problematic because I was
gonna come on here be like you were you
when she was both onto the same design
you birth bought the same dress right
but if anything you styled it
differently if it's looking like Ariana
had a designer make a custom piece based
off of what someone customed them
themselves and made themselves and
design themselves then that is a little
a little you know it's not great yeah
okay that's interesting but I feel like
Ariana has her own custom designers so
like luxury law that's for stylist right
so if she was like was making custom
with someone else wore I guess yeah
that's copying but it doesn't sound like
it was like her personal designer either
because the pheromone said could I don't
fault the designer because the designer
she hired was a local queen and paid
them a lot of money to do it money they
couldn't turn down and then was honest
with me about it so no I don't fault the
drag queen that made it at all Ariana
has coin don't you feel like ariana
grande should just be like handing out
NDA's for anyone she works with no I
need to know if it was the same designer
now I don't think it was from from what
it's sounding like it sounds like Farrah
made that you think no she she's the
designer she like that's what they do on
drag racing they make design looks mm
but then she said I do I do own that
look I wore it on national television
and it's in my closet I just think it's
wrong for someone to claim their for
lgbtq but then steal from them it's not
cute okay I just want to say that
claiming she's not for LGBTQ rights when
she has done so much for the community
and has always been like an outspoken
ally that's taking it too far and that's
like slandering and I don't agree with
that but you want to call [ __ ] out for
copying you like cool on there yeah I do
I need more information actually because
King in her closet she owns the look in
the sense that what she designed it I
mean you just I think went back to do I
on Pharos n did she design it or is it
off the rack right did she buy it
somewhere did she collab with a designer
who's now collabing with re
I just think and then when you look at
the two photos it's like yes they're
wearing the same body
but it's not like she copied her look
entirely like Ariana's hair she has her
little space buttons
she has her choker like it's if ariana
grande had come out with pink hair like
Farrah and the same jewelry right it
would have been more of an attack on
Farrah but just stealing someone's
outfit I don't know if that warrants
like a an allegation of copying yeah I
don't think that it does so unless it's
her decide the age-old question where do
you draw the line between copying and
being inspired by honestly for me
personally I draw the line like really
far away like I know a lot of people and
I think type how does one of those
people who are pretty strict about like
inspiration versus plagiarism um I think
there are so many different factors
especially like price points where it's
like and I see all the time like the
stylish jeans group where people are
like I love this dress has anyone seen a
dupe for it written by dupe you mean
similar but for less a copy yeah but
technically that's a crime I don't know
that person the that designer who's
duping it should be shamed but like
there are so many people that like don't
want to experience this sort of fashion
but like can't afford it so like what
was she just not it just it becomes to
an elitist yeah I took I mean I totally
agree I feel like in the in the
conversation of copying verse in Spain
inspired by it's really a case-by-case
thing like there's no flat rule yeah and
I think when like if it's the same exact
price point and it's similar
then it's copying same butter you're
making something for so much less and
like you're getting inspired by runway
looks I think that's fine like fashion
should be for everyone and like there's
so there are so few ideas that are like
so proprietary that it's like a genius
idea it's like honestly if stripe is a
stripe a great and there's a cutout and
a dress is a dress sometimes in like
it's possible and that's even happened
with us where like we've said something
that it turns out that someone else has
already said because like we both have
brains and we came to the same idea you
know what I mean well like um I mean I
know I know like we like there are some
thoughts that are just not original
special know what time its original take
we all kind of think in the same way and
you end up saying the same thing and I
don't resent any other podcast that
might have said something shocking you
know what it's like John Paul Jones like
there's a meme going around
he's literally the love child of 10
Things I Hate About You he's ledger and
Julia Stiles and I saw like four
different people who posted it genuinely
thinking the same thing like not
stealing it it's possible that people
can come to the same thought and not be
copying yes yeah a hundred percent like
people can have the same thought in
terms of this Ariana Grande I think I
just need a few more details before I
make my official judge yeah I'm not
gonna make my official judgement yet
because but don't come for Ariana saying
she's like no I redesigned it throws a
wrench into what I originally thought ya
know if they're made by the same
designer it's not a big deal but if
Ariana contracted a separate designer to
copy or be inspired by this look that
she created and not give credit you can
I don't think it's so terrible that she
got a designer to copy someones look she
was like so what someone was wearing
it's flattering but give cry their like
to an Instagram post or a tweeter like
tweeter think so
so I have a question for you say I see
an influencer wearing something and I go
and buy it because I like it on them and
I posted up me in this outfit on my
Instagram not outfit like one piece and
then it sounded differently should I be
tagging that influencer okay two things
to say one if it's available at a store
know the making having it be
custom-designed yes and when you're
ariana grande and you probably did copy
like it would just be a cool thing for
her to do yeah not saying she has to but
it could have avoided this entire
situation if like when the video came
out she did it side by side of me being
like loved what you said like that's
what button is absolutely that's when
it's an inspirational being shady about
it that's what it's copying but okay
there's difference between being shady
and like hiding something versus just
not like liking something going out and
making it for yourself and then wearing
it like I don't think that that's
necessarily shady like it's in public I
got I don't know I'm not sure I don't
know either like it's just we're too in
the weeds here right silver bind
vibrates a silver body's so cute she
could have avoided what I'm saying she
could have avoided this entire thing
just by doing a tweet you know or even
just reaching out but I don't even think
she knew that she needed something that
she was trying to avoid something I
don't know what right you have a team of
people like you got a look you got to
look at every situation of her freely I
don't know I think it's a little bit of
a stretch I think it's a stretch to
accused ariana grande and not being a
true ally of the lgbtq+ community
that's a stretch agree that is a reach
yeah okay
next up Kim Kardashian leaks her own
baby news after getting drunk at a
Christmas party Kim Kardashian spilled
the baby beans in a new clip from
Keeping Up with the Kardashians which is
coming back soon and I was so excited
the reality star reveals she leaked the
news that she and her husband Kanye were
expecting their fourth child after
getting too boozy at their Christmas Eve
party quote how is it that everybody
found out about your surrogate by the
way Scott Disick asked him during a meal
with Kris and Khloe quote I got drunk on
Christmas Eve and I told someone on
Christmas even I don't remember who I
told because I was drunk
multiple people Scott asked I think so
Kim said relatable but here's where I
find initiates like if you're being
honored with an invitation to the
Christmas Kardashian party like shut
your [ __ ] mouth like there was a leak
there if I was there and came to tell me
something I wouldn't say a [ __ ] word
wouldn't been so grateful to been
invited what Little Snitch is running
around being grateful for the invitation
shut your [ __ ] mouth
yeah I just want to get back to this
Ariana thing because Hannah only blaze
making a point here that I just want to
address because she's saying the problem
here is that Ariana what going on to say
that forever21 copped her look and is
suing them and so it's because of that
suit however that's a great play I think
the suit comes into play if they were
just selling those um those buns she
wore on the top of her head and they put
them on like a random model and they're
just selling the buns that I think that
would be fine but they used a model that
looks like her they used her lyrics and
as if to say like this is Ariana
endorsed like agree no no and what they
did is definitely worse but I see the
point now that Farrah is making like
haha yeah that's why it's that's why
she's bringing it up now I understand
but then when it comes to the suit it's
not about the fact that they're selling
what she wore which is problematic in
itself but a lot of people do that all
time I said they're using like her her
likeness wax figure yeah and using her
totally garnished her mic but I guess as
it relates back to the forever 21 suit I
understand why Sarah is now coming out
and saying why now why this Berg because
I'm sure she's felt this way for a long
time I know seeing Ariana come for
someone else it's like the jury getting
like she's probably been feeling this
way for quite some time yes that I
understand so the timing all makes sense
the time of the league as now the
perfume oh so yeah but the lines really
are blurred here
I don't know what what the answer is if
we need like stricter laws right but you
know when you're getting into like
creativity I feel like this problem
exists on the internet a lot too it's
like where are the lines right I don't
know so everyone makes up their own like
personal set of ethics and codes and
then that doesn't work for other people
yeah you know Kim spoiling her baby news
oh yeah well it actually makes a lot of
sense because I remembered the news just
being like so like casual and like kind
of messy when in the past she's been
very strategic about her announcements
for everything she just makes a lot of
sense I'm just like really upset that
like someone would take an invitation to
that party and betray their trust that's
true I think everyone who goes those
parties would have to sign an NDA and
it's like their inner circle it's like
if you walk in it's not fun like I agree
they should be signing India's no
because you're coming to a party is like
hard I want to still have yeah you're
super famous like I want my friends to
feel like my friends and not like
they're talking to me and they're also
under contract now they have to think
about what they what they remembered
from the part and I some [ __ ] is is that
if you're invited to a family affair you
don't need the NDA like you're in the
circle of trust
maybe when the party was at Chris's
house you know chris is famous for
having a stack of ndas at the entrance
of her house like I mean when was that
Christmas Howie yeah maybe maybe then
people signed NDA's just cuz she had so
many on hand but now that it's been
transferred over to the West's maybe not
I just feel like ever since Kylie was
able to keep her baby a secret like they
trust their friends more like as Kylie
was at the Christmas party last night
super pregnant and not one photo leaked
that's why the Jordan wood scandal which
like now doesn't seem like such a big
deal is such a big deal like the trust
in that family is like valued over
anything yeah Jordan betrayed that trust
yeah so but I feel like that proved to
them like oh maybe we can't trust some
people but then Jordan did what she did
and now they're like and the guards up
kylie is like all in on sauce she's all
in on all of her friends Oreo I think
she took out like at one point she was
giving all of her friendship energy to
Jordan and now she's taking that energy
away and dividing it she's she's it's
like the crown I mean Gretchen weiners a
piece for sauce a piece for Sophia
Ritchie
yeah no justice for URI she's taken
inventory of her friendship and is
moving forward in a more you know
egalitarian manner yes and I'm so here
for it like Kylie Jenner egalitarian
Queen Kylie
like best friend it's 11:11 I really
want to be kylie jenner's like best
friend like honestly that's all I want
this world I would give up Theo
Theodor know why but know that she's my
friend she would never make me no she
would never make me the guys have so
much in common your dogs would play with
her dogs because they all love farmers
dog oh my god yes that's so true Theo
has been on like this diet because I
feel like I've been feeding Theo kibble
for like a few well like a year and a
half and homeboy is [ __ ] starving
like everywhere he goes he's trying to
eat stuff off the floor he up for one
point was eating his own Judy okay like
that's at that time malnourished she was
I think I said it realize it like kibble
is like fast food like it's not good
it's not feeling mother like son it's
true it's just trash I don't set a very
good example in the house at the edges
like watches what I do but that's why
the farmers dog is a smarter healthier
pet food and Kylie uses it so I was
using it like a few months before Kylie
was now I feel like this [ __ ] is
copying me the farmers dog believes you
shouldn't be the only one eating healthy
like you we love our pets so much and
care about their health like what that's
why they created the farmers dog a
service that delivers balanced freshly
made pet food with simple recipes guided
by science and driven by love
so now Theo has had a fancier groomer
than me he has had a fancier wardrobe
than me and now he has a fancier food
distributor yeah like the word he has a
diet your diet oh my god what's wrong
with us we're not allowed to say that
word anymore that's right so it's real
food human grade meat and veggies and
simple recipes made for dogs it gives
you quality and peace of mind because
it's fresh wholesome ingredients gently
cooked to meet the USDA standards while
using vet designed recipes from a
rigorous safety standards to recurring
personalized celebrities we make it easy
for what's best for your dog and it's
more healthy because a fresh diet of
food that is linked to wealth and health
benefits so you get a smoother coat
clearer skin regulated weight better
poops I can definitely attest to that I
need this fresher breath that's been the
biggest blessing and more balanced
energy levels and I just really find
like the biggest hook for me was that
Theo wasn't trying to eat literally
everything like now he lays on my bed
while I'm eating and he lets me eat like
before that he was like literally up
down my throat like trying to take the
food out of my mouth it was so annoying
so our if your dog's health and
well-being are too important to worry
about feeding him some highly processed
burnt brown kibble we've made the switch
dog it's real food made fresh and
delivered right to your door I truly
feel like this is it no I agree and
Theo's been saying such great things
about farmers dog
then he doesn't stop talking dead it
makes me want to get my own it's a
smarter healthier option making it as
simple as possible to give your dog a
better diet start your trial today go to
the farmers dog calm slash toast you'll
say 50% off and get free shipping that's
the farmers dog calm slash toast for 50%
off your trial with free shipping the
farmers dog.com flesh toast Kiley
approve toast approved Co approved
te o approved in as you know cos a
doctor so his word means the most heat
right because doctors will get sick no
and like doctors Sony garbage no they
can't be thought yeah definitely it
would be bad from practice he says own
advertisement right anyways exciting
times it was a fun ad that wasn't fun
out of fun segue and I feel as though we
don't we haven't spoken about the
Kardashians like ad nauseam in a long
time like because they right now they're
yeah they've been off the air they're
just like being quiet it's like Taylor
season um but I've really miss talking
about that me too and I just I'm really
excited for keeping up to come back cuz
you there make like when people ask
about like our show I'm like you know we
just talk about the Kardashians baba
bhot I'm like actually Sebastian this is
that's very Taylor Swift but that's the
happening that's the flavor of the week
that is the flavor of the week she's
just oh my god Wow yesterday was the
longest day ever because I did Taylor
Swift so psycho how was it did I miss
something steamy
as hell obviously about going opened
with state of grace closed with Cornelia
Street in between we had ever it was
incredible we suck job it was so good I
just couldn't get out of bed I
understand but like you would look five
o'clock like that's when my days over
you know yeah no but it was honestly I
was so healthy yesterday I also kept
cooked as everyone Son and circle isn't
shocking it was shocking well sack and I
were like what should we do for dinner
should we go out but I was doing
SoulCycle so I wasn't wearing makeup and
I was like I actually have a grocery
delivery coming and I have meat coming
and like zucchini
eggplant and I just got this cauliflower
rice and I was like maybe I should cook
and this up what you learned - you're
killing any class it is I kind of want
to go back to school because I lost all
my notes um so if anyone's at home with
me I'd come with you okay because I do
it too we give the first class being
three hours like I can't it goes by
really quickly I need that food that's
true and it's kosher so like you can eat
it yeah and if we all go together there
would be way more fun than when I went
alone okay okay I'll go okay cool I'll
set it you know we both IRS okay next
story crazy rich Asians co-writer Adel
Lim exits equals overpay disparity crazy
Adel Lim who wrote the crazy rich agent
screenplay has exited the plant sequels
due to a dispute over pay disparity a
representative for Lim confirmed her
departure from the Warner Brothers
projects the rep declined to comment
further Warner Brothers did not respond
to a request for comment this is so
crazy I feel like when crazy rich Asians
first came out it was like really
revered as like this you know special
like progressive film and it's just been
caught up in some like drums like
between the constants who have it all
and now this equality pay gap like yeah
shadiness ya know they gotta get it
together she seen this ever see if he
was so good and like so perfect and so I
have to believe Adele Lin played a large
she's responsible and I don't want to
see a sequel that doesn't include every
person who worked on the first one
United I could live with our constant
slow but yeah but like the movie I'm
just doing what I like knowing what I
know it's tough but I like her as an
actress like I would have never that's
why those claims were so shocking that
such a dish of value good of an actor
diva than Jennifer Lopez on the set of
hustlers
um I feel like Jennifer Lopez gets like
a really bad rap as a diva but she's
just like a down-home girl really thanks
I feel like I've never really gotten
that vibe from her that she gets that
kind of rap I feel like she's very
low-key
no I feel like she she is in reality
low-key but when you think of JLo it's
like you know icon legend diva like I
don't think of her in that way I think
she's done a great job of really putting
yourself out there was just Jenny from
the walk ya know I don't know if she has
this I kind of like Mariah Carey thing
about her in mind I mean Mariah Carey is
a species of her own like she is the
diva diva of all yeah
she's a proud Eva yeah that there's
nothing cool about that like when
there's a diva who you only know like
from like behind the scenes like whisper
that they're a diva like they try and
hide their like evilness that's when
they're actually like a diva like Mariah
Carey being so upfront and like extra
taking Andy Cohen seat and like just
making him be there alone like she's so
openness with her you know demoness that
I feel like in reality she's not that
big of a monster the monsters are the
one who keep their demoness quiet the
divas in sheep's clothing the divas
nonsense whoo yeah that's why it's so
crazy that's what it is but it's also so
crazy because like [ __ ] you ate that
famous yet like you haven't ten years
before you came and started actually
like that Mariah Carey's been around a
walk yeah she's several times yeah and
so was Jenni she's been around her old
lock yeah I agree
anyways I wonder what she was getting
paid and what other people are getting
paid in like if there's a way that we
can bridge this gap here I know like
what the [ __ ] yeah maybe if it gets
enough isn't that sort of setting though
like this girl wrote one of the biggest
rom-coms last year like it was heralded
it was in in the Oscars but it was also
a rom-com it was the first Asian
American lead like this girl did
everything right in writing the first
movie and she still can't get paid
equally yeah what does one have to do to
get paid she's getting paid considering
the movie made 238 million dollars
worldwide so like I don't know what a
film writer gets yeah and I wonder like
what she would have gotten for a sequel
and I wonder what the other people are
getting I need some numbers here yeah
these are financial reports the theme
today is any more facts that's true you
know so I'm gonna hold my judgment
speaking of facts and speaking of
sadness the the jewel epidemic is is is
speedy is it's wild out here what's
happening okay first of all the second
vaping related death Oh happened like a
sweet death and Michigan is actually
going to ban flavored East cigarettes or
the curb the youth vaping epidemic but
there have been a lot of articles coming
out that vaping is really [ __ ]
terrible I've seen quite a few stories
about people who had up in the hospital
had trouble breathing and it's
definitely taking its toll on me I am
the end of my jewel relationship me too
person I always said like by the end of
summer you'll see just ulle and I'm
outside and these stories are just
bringing me to a quicker end nap I don't
know does September 2014
no I think I'm like really in the last
couple days of my jewel it's just I've
been needing to slowly wean off of it
because I'm definitely addicted and I'm
I'm pretty much done it's weird because
I'm not addicted like during the week my
jewel sits somewhere and I don't know
where it is and then on the weekend when
I go to an outdoor concert or I'm like
drinking I really started drooling so
that I would drink less and it helped
but like I'm now addicted to the the
oriole situation and the thing to do
with my hand because it's like for every
sip of a drink I was taking now I hit
the jewel and so that's like it's the
physical act it's not even like the
nicotine mental thing I mean completely
agree so I don't know what to do I don't
want to get a Badgett spinner no but
like what about my mouth I mean I don't
know yeah I don't know but I'm kind of
over it I'm over it completely so Oregon
beat death patient used he/she THC
device from dispensary Oregon's public
health physician said Wednesday that a
person who died recently of a severe
respiratory illness had used a vaping
device containing marijuana oil that was
purchased at a legal dispensary
that's just like a weed pin I don't know
yeah it's like can you write it in like
terms that we refer to these things
right what's a THC device a THC did
being device with marijuana oil that has
to be a weed pen that's just that's not
a jewel no sorry it's not jewel specific
it's vaping so is vaping just anything
that's not like with fire yeah it's so
it's like all the different cigarettes
out there well Ben now also marijuana
well
pen yeah the death is the second linked
by public health officials nationwide to
vaping and the first link to product
purchase at a matter of marijuana
dispensary public health authorities in
Oregon haven't determined what sick in
the middle aged adult or whether the
person may have added something to the
liquid or tampered with the device after
it was purchased
said a public health physician very very
sad so so so sad a lesson to all you
will listen and related is that now that
Michigan is banning flavored
e-cigarettes
state health investigators are looking
into six possible cases of vaping
related lung diseases you ever get those
videos on Instagram of like kids in
their cars doing the crazy tricks with
their boobs like those huge chunky babe
said like I don't know what what's in
them but it's like tons of smoke and
they're like making hearts and like
jumping through them yeah those videos
are hilarious they're insane he's
putting these kids out of business
totally I know a funny it's really crazy
like it's like that MTV commercial like
we are the guinea pigs
yeah kids need to just truly stop they
Bing start taking their vitamins and
like start washing their hair yeah I
think now and every time I go to hit
like the jewel I'm gonna just take a
vitamin from Carol that's what you
should do it without honestly is a
grateful solution Carol makes sure what
you're putting into your body comes from
the best sources backed by honest
guidance and transparency all available
on their website so carob is a website
that has a quiz and you know we'd love a
quiz the last you a bunch of questions
about like your well-being when I felt
it out I said I just get really fatigued
in the afternoon and I have terrible
memory and a bunch of other things and
they put together like little packages
of vitamins for you like what they
recommend you can say like you're not
into like trying out like Eastern like
new types of vitamins you just want you
know the regular stuff so I got like
milk thistle ashwaganda I think I got
like a b12 it's really helpful also
because they send you the the pills in
little packages so it's one package per
day so you get throw a bunch in your bag
if you're traveling it makes it really
easy like then there's like Monday
Tuesday Wednesday I like a ziploc bag
ala Lisa Rinna yeah that one's gonna
start a rumor about you
they have vegan and vegetarian
supplements available to match your
dietary needs and the individually
wrapped vitamin packs are now made from
compostable plant-based film that meet
the same safety standards so your
vitamins are kept fresh while now being
better for the environment for 25
dollars 25 percent excuse me off your
first care of order go to take care of
comm and enter the code toast again if
you want 25 percent off your first care
of order go to take care of comm and
enter Coke toast I first did it I think
it was like a thorn bush now Instagram
story and I swept up from her a user
code so now I'm paying it forward use
our code take care of comm code toast
for 25% off yeah it's important to take
care of yourselves like there's no C's
now that summer is over I feel like
everyone let's everything go Johnny
summer I know it's like everyone works
all year for their summer body and
that's
what I did and then the second it was
like may I just stopped like I stopped
caring I've got a haircut me any haircut
today
I literally have been eating like
McDonald's like multiple times a week
like I need you get my life together I'm
like I'm embarrassed like I look in the
mirror and I'm like who the [ __ ] is that
wench when I'm looking when she is [ __ ]
and I feel like taking vitamins and
doing it through care of is actually the
easiest thing you can do and wanted like
the most important things you know
Jackie we're on the same page let's talk
about Real Housewives of Dallas I
finally returned without carried uber
but with another carry who I like a lot
very boring and you know I was watching
the old episodes before they were
playing like the reunion and last season
and I was watching it also being so
bored by it and I'm really thinking
these ladies need to step it up like
their franchise their seasons are not
given like if they get picked up for
another season it's always a blessing
yeah and there are not what's going on
right now is not cutting up yeah the
first episode of every house I sit is
always pretty boring because we're just
catching up with the ladies and it
sounds like for most of these ladies
like not much has changed
and it also didn't see each other like
why I thought they were real friends
yeah except I I think Brady and
Stephanie um and like Cameron and Lea
and friends with like some people and
she sees them probably around I
understand like it takes a minute for
everyone to get back together but we're
gonna have to speed it up here you know
yeah and like oh by the way oh my god I
was thinking it and then when Stephanie
said it I was still glad like literally
Deanna and Leon are starting it to the
same person I know and like last season
they were the same person they had super
dark long hair yeah and now like the
fact that they both went lighter it was
like when Bethenny and LuAnn had the
same haircut
and same haircut as Jacques yes no
totally that was actually really funny I
just think there's not a lot they're
like they're really putting the season
on the back of this DeAndre and Leeanne
fight it's not that internal and like
fights from last season aren't and this
goes for any franchise like you can't
bring over last season drama and have it
be the main storyline of this season by
the way where I'm having taste you up it
with Deandra her mom gave her the
company but it sucks I know unless year
last year was her mom gave her the
company but didn't really matter it's
the same premise like she was tricked
yeah and now it's like just watching
DeAndre and
finances like it's making me so stressed
also like I was getting a little annoyed
because I actually really liked Andhra
but kind of like our entitlement when it
comes to her mom's company and just like
money that she didn't earn like I I just
get like a bad taste in my mouth like
complaining to her mom that her mom gave
her a broken company like it wasn't
broken when the mom had it why'd you
take the Christian TV commercials off
the air right it seems like a simple
solutions like that was your fault right
you know it's like okay revenue went
down ever since we stopped advertising
on Christian TV go let's start
advertising on Christian TV or like
maybe the morning toast I don't know if
you're trying to reach Millennials like
we're right here ya know it's so it's I
just don't like the way that she kind of
talks about her mom and the company and
the trust like so disrespectful and you
know what like she has the biggest
advertising platform on Real Housewives
right now so like that's actually a
problem if it's still in the tank right
because any business on Housewives is a
guaranteed success yeah and she already
had an established business like with
products people could go to buy like
it's been around for a while people we
trusted so that's actually really weird
that they don't have sales when they're
on a TV show yeah also I think filming
and sitting down on a bench in a
cemetery is also just like a little
weird no it's not a recipe for success
no but also talking a seeing Deana it
just really reminded me about like all
the people we met in Dallas like she has
a same exact voice at Saks grandma Roz
yeah and you know Roz when she goes to
the beauty shop they tell her she looks
like Dee Simmons she has the same hair
oh man that's so funny but she's
brunette and yeah is one that is
hysterical but it's also really
interesting because what I like about
the Dallas franchises for the most part
like everyone's [ __ ] rich like I know
Jimmy see Carrie's house he lives in
Highland Park she has that modern house
such like oh is Brown yeah my style but
anything but it's in Highland Park now
Deandra lives in Highland Park Camryn
lives in Highland Park
Stephanie lives in Highland Park Brandi
does have a Brandis house is so nice
every time they do an aerial view I'm
like Tam it's [ __ ] huge because when
they show up from the front just looks
like a regular mansion but from the top
it's a contention and her kid would you
rather live in Highland Park in like an
artsy nice house like deandra's or
Kerry's or live in like Brandis house I
think I'd rather live in Brandis house
she lives on a golf course like she'd
done it as a country club it's so nice
now that you like been to Dallas and
like experience it like encounter high
resort we went Island Park we had the
time of our
and we only drove through Highland Park
unlike the main streets and even though
I like the main roads have the [ __ ]
huge house oh then like right off the
highway it's like you feel like you're
in high it's really different yeah so do
you have do you look at the show
differently now well I like to have more
respect for Highland Park I have more
respect for Stephanie who was the
biggest and nicest house in Highland
Park
yeah but now we know where we sring
about her oh yes yes thank you for
reminding because we came on the show
thinking like the richest one is Cameron
I think she does most family money but
just like her like day-to-day spending
is it is it not even near Stephanie's
but I got really concerned about
Stephanie because she was talking about
how Travis should help out Deandra just
like business chat and she was telling
the audience how when Travis took over
the family locker company from his
father they were doing roughly 7 million
dollars a year and now that trumps took
it over in the past 10 years it's
escalated to 75 million which is so
impressive don't get me wrong I used a
Holman locker yesterday at cell cycle
you did yeah they're all the lockers at
soul cycle and Equinox is interesting so
then it got me thinking about okay so
Travis is the CEO of a seventy-five
million dollar a year company which is
so great but like what is the CEO get of
seventy five million after costs and
salaries and bonuses like I can't
imagine homeboys making more than like
fifteen or twenty even then I think is
high I even that I think is high so I
just feel like they're living like a
little bit beyond their means like for
the show they just bought this huge
house that was like millions of dollars
put a million dollars into it like
flying private like I just I just I
don't want them to you know fall into
like the housewives curse of like living
beyond your means for the show you think
the show's gonna make you a star it
could sustain this lifestyle I just I
want to put it out there maybe they have
other forms of revenue that I don't know
maybe like Stephanie comes from a lot of
money I don't know maybe but I also
think that Travis um is a good
businessman in general he goes to
Harvard Business School every year so I
don't think he would allow them to live
about there no I trust Travis I give me
shitty vibes no he does not give me
shady guys operations yeah it's like
when you have a tangible product it's
like oh I see how it went for I never
heard of it when your dad was the CEO
and now it is it yesterday like when
it's in every NFL locker oh yeah but
when like you have a business that you
either can't explain or like no one
knows what you do like that's when it's
really shaken it's like not a tangible
item it's like we are the middleman yeah
yeah but because it's a tangible item
like I think his business
solid um I think he's a solid guy SWAT
even though I am a man and I love that I
just I just I heard it and I was like I
thought it would be more just based on
like for the way that they lived like
you would think they run a
billion-dollar company right yeah I
agree with that
okay but I'm not worried about them
because either I think they're so
they're so cute and I firmly still
believe that like Stephanie home and is
on track to being one of the greatest
housewives of all time I couldn't agree
is also falling into line like I think
season one he saw himself on TV he was
like I wasn't being like a little bit of
a dick and has a normal reaction that
happens a lot of the times but he was
also a great housewife has growth like
season one Stephanie like she was
definitely quiet she was definitely a
type of housewife who like didn't have a
lot of independence like really relied
on her husband and like through the
housewives it's become like a mutually
beneficial relationship where it's like
this has given her purpose like a grade
they are more of equals and like that's
a queen I can root for it's like someone
who is about changing not someone who
just started out as like the [ __ ] right
no no she was definitely like a like me
I think that's ominously what's wrong
with Lisa Vanderpump it's like she
started she was so great like she had it
all going on and like from where she
started to where she finished she never
came she's the same person she never
evolved that's right she just like one
time like got a new house
yeah um Brandis kids are so [ __ ] cute
and the sass from the older one I was
shocked I'm like a [ __ ] slapped
across my face it was making me really
nervous to have kids like and then we
when we met Carrie's teenage daughter
who is also being rude term I was like
how do you have kids that aren't rude to
you by the way that was what was really
shocking because that kid is like old
enough to know better
especially she's on camera like she's
that rude to her mom on the first day of
filming when like you're supposed to be
your best like I remember Peggy so honey
Ann's kids like being in the kitchen
like Yes Mother like butts when is
busting your own [ __ ] camera on TV
then being so rude to her that day like
I can only imagine what they're like off
camera they said they seemed like
monsters honestly or maybe sometimes
teenagers think it's cool to be mean
maybe yes just like hamming it up from
the camera like mom that's skirt you're
ruining middle life
yeah I think actually she might have
just been being a little extra maybe for
the cameras the other day having a 10:30
curfew on a weeknight is very [ __ ]
gracious yeah I really love my house on
a weekly going that's school you have
homework no I thought that was weird
nabo she's like 15 16 yeah yeah where
the [ __ ] are you going on a weeknight
yeah calm down like yeah Kara seems cool
I look forward to getting to know her
meet you she sounds she's being really
fun it's confusing that they chose
another cow
but actually you know it just you could
like pretend it's the same person and
they're friends um but other than that
should be a fine season I don't have
like amazing high hopes for it but I'm
looking forward to the drops look I'm
looking forward to the fight between
Cameron and Leanne me too because
because that friendship makes no sense
they had blind loyally loyalty towards
each other and the bet it's like kind of
like Vicky and Kelly Dodd wears I think
they're they were so close so fast but
they were also like protecting each
other and then you hear about Trane when
the first when the friendship dissolves
right she also had a thought about
Bronwyn because I was thinking about her
behavior this week and like how it was
off and how it was often she really
confused because she came into the group
like she's just like this a perfect
person and like she was so disrespectful
to Vicki for no reason when she met her
I guess except for her like touching her
husband's arm and she just like said to
her straight up like I don't like you
were like you're not my kind of girl
asleep and I was like and then for like
literally the next week for it to come
out that like she like has no back but
mighty have fallen like it was just like
who do you think you are right no no
she's a little chick all over the place
I am no Vicki stand but like have
respect for the og of the OC also I
didn't see this on yesterday's episode
but I'm then - cuz I was thinking it
like she needs to stop blaming her mom
for whatever issues she has socially
like she sounds like she's a very lovely
child to her mom was the doctor worked
so hard and think I'd ruin grandparents
who take care of you like I don't
I was bopped around she done that she
was like an army kid who was shuffling
around the country and her mom was like
taken aback by that like because you're
having problems with your friends that
somehow my fault no and like you go on
TV and now the first time you want to
talk about it is with their cameras and
their think my yes I'm like basically
making her out to be like a bad mom I'm
not liking the way she's handling things
I couldn't agree more and I really liked
her in the beginning and like each
instance is so different if she was
consistently like spineless or
consistently like rude and - Vicki like
headstrong fine but like to be all of
these things I'm like who are you it
feels like you're just doing things for
television and that's not what I want to
see Jackie I want to get to know who you
are already um before we wrap up for
today because we don't get to do to your
toasters yesterday we are going to do it
today if you are new here to your
toasters is our advice segment you can
email us to your toasters at gmail.com
it is always anonymous and will answer
questions give advice about work
relationships dating we really like the
weirder the better like the girl whose
boyfriend donated to a sperm bank it
didn't tell her
that was good one so hopefully today's
are quite as interesting snitch chose
them for us dear snatchler Jackie oh and
the girl who sings toast recently I've
been noticing odd changes in my dad's
work schedule he's been staying at the
office late going into work on the
weekends and taking more work trips you
know how old this person is that they're
like so up on their dad schedule totally
cuz I do they live with their dad I feel
guilty for a lot so high school toasters
what's good I feel guilty for allowing
myself to even think it but I thought
maybe he's having an affair a few years
ago when I left for college okay so
she's like 25 when I left for college my
dad and I shared our location using the
find my friends app on our phones as a
safety thing it's not weird it's not
weird I don't think he realizes that I
can also see where he is one weekend my
mom and I were away visiting family and
had a weird urge to check my god so
patient it was about 10:30 p.m. on a
Saturday and yet absolutely no reason to
be anywhere about home when I searched
his location he was not home I texted
him to ask him where he was and he lied
and said he was home after this I
started to check on this location daily
and found that he was at this address up
to three times a week I have such a
close bond with my dad and I feel like I
have to find a way to talk to him about
this every huge pit in my stomach
because I know what he is doing but I
can't tell anyone because my mom is
terminally ill I know if I were to bring
this a ferret away it would crush my mom
and cause her stress and that quite
literally could kill her I feel like if
I were to tell her about the affair and
it affects her health and then it'll all
be my fault so torn about what to do I
love with my parents so much and I don't
want to hurt either one of them but what
my dad is doing is not okay what do I do
a torn toaster it's a confirmed affair
like she went to the address and so I
was either motel or a woman's home no
but I think it's safe to say this isn't
an episode of like friends where it's
like Chandler's having a funeral you
know it's a realization like you know
it's like what maybe it's a therapist
maybe he's going through a lot like
first of all I think the very least just
go to the address she was going to
therapy at 10:30 p.m. on a Saturday if
you work really hard and work really
late hours but she said 30 p.m. on
Saturdays shady but you know what just
like first don't assume the worst go to
the address what is it motel right there
just a lady's house google it even if
they call this bowling league like
there's so many things he could be doing
as a release as a stress release for
what he's going through and I'm not
gonna lie it's most likely an affair
yeah it could be something else so just
first go check it out now we're under no
circumstances tell your mom right let's
deal with the fact that if it is an
affair say you go first go and check it
out now
it's an affair um do not tell your mom
this is your burden now well yeah this
is your cross today this is your cross
to bear I think that totally the right
thing to do is your mom never finds out
and you know what like you can't imagine
what it's like to be not not that I'm
making any excuses but it's like I'm
sure it hasn't been easy on the dad
either to have his wife be going through
this and I don't think it's an excuse
but like people cope in fucked-up ways
so honestly this is your burden that I
think you just have to take with you to
the grave yeah and maybe if you want you
can talk to your dad about it that would
make you feel better you don't want to
go through it alone you don't have like
someone else to talk to but I wouldn't
confront him and say you have to tell
mom like I would say what's going on and
maybe I mean I've heard of people but I
don't even think he should tell mom no
no no no but so she might say like she's
not gonna tell her mom but like now dad
has to tell her like no one should tell
mom
no like but you should talk to him about
it and hear what he has to say because
there are a lot of like I've heard of
people who are in relationships but
either like a person is ill or has
Alzheimer's or where the person is
really not there and like in the the
caretaker and it depends how long you
know this person is in sick for but
sometimes it's years and like the person
that they love is in there any right or
the sick person allows them yes so there
are times when like that caretaker like
does start dating and meeting other
people and it's not even in like a
solution Oh salacious type of way it's
just like this person their whole life
is taking care of someone else who they
love so much who's no longer there and
they deserve some joy as well so I think
every situation is different but but
talk to your dad about it because I
agree it sounds like he might he's been
a P John like your whole life and people
don't just become like terrible people
maybe your mom already yeah you you
never know what the situation is so like
first don't assume the worst
but then say it's an affair just talk to
your dad yes hey what's going on I agree
I think we gave some good advice there
thank you for sharing
oh it's anonymous you're sorry for that
because it's really hard and we're
thinking and praying for your mom I have
a big family with lots of cousins and
we're all very close to the cousin in
question let's call her amy is 19 and
always been a bit of a mess I'm recently
engaged I'm preparing to ask for my
bridesmaids
it's that question that I'm having all
my cousins except I don't want to ask
about a year and a half ago she started
dating a 33 year old man who has two
children with two different women no
judgment except both girls were 18 money
the mop he has no real career he thinks
he's an MMA fighter when he really just
fights with people at the county fair
the kicker is that he was arrested last
summer for having sex with a 13 year old
girl he cheated on Amy with a literal
child but she aggressively stands up for
him the family is drawn back from Amy
because we're all so disgusted she
basically chose him over us she even
stopped speaking to our grandfather he
still supports her financially because
he told her that he didn't approve our
grandfather is a sweetie and our
grandmother recently passed away so her
behavior has been so so so hard on him
like he's cried to me about it
my boyfriend has also gone into
screaming matches with Amy's mom back to
bridesmaids my mom says I have to ask
her because it would break my
grandmother's heart if I didn't ask her
the compromise my mom put Bharat is
asking Amy but making it clear that her
boyfriend can't come to the wedding or
the after party and if she brings him
they would be asked to leave she's the
kind of person who would try to sneak
him into the party just to your bellies
and be an [ __ ] I think that if I
asked her and tell her boyfriend that
she that her boyfriend can't come she'll
just decide to not be in the wedding but
then do I invite her at all it does make
me sad to think about not having her
being at my wedding but I refuse to have
a little predator at my wedding what do
i do do I risk her Andres drama do I ask
do I not ask and risk hurting feelings
and guilt on my part please help okay
like I can't believe you're even
decidedly should I have her in my
wedding like the question is should I
invite her totally like homegirl does
not get to be a bridesmaid and like you
could just say like hey like sorry we
just have this rule like no sex
offenders are invited right like there
are the flower girls like they're
children around right no I like 100% her
man's not invited I personally don't
think you need to ask her to be a
bridesmaid at all like first of all even
if you just didn't like her and that's
why you didn't want to ask her it is
your date it's so good I get what her
mom's saying it's like all the cousins
are bridesmaids they're like the grandma
would be rolling over in her break you
know what there are punishments for your
actions and like you don't just get to
like date a sex offender bring him
around to everyone and like torture
everyone and like and sure honestly I
think that's a bad joke get off on your
mom's back cut off your grandpa and then
you still get all the perks of being a
cousin like no this is your punishment
for making shitty life choices also like
your she doesn't talk to her grandpa
anymore who's still alive but your mom
is worried it's gonna break the
grandmother's heart who's dead
like know this is a bad call on your
mom's part she's giving you a pit for no
reason like get this [ __ ] out of here
don't invite her and don't make
everybody and I personally think you
don't have to have anyone who's a
bridesmaid in your wedding you don't
even need a
reason and like you have like this yeah
ten solid reasons why she's not allowed
to be a bridesmaid so now the question
is you invite her to the wedding without
a plus-one oh good you could've been her
you can invite her his family yeah well
thank you for submitting a test again
dear toasters at gmail.com anything from
you know wedding stuff bridesmaid stuff
work stuff relationship stuff moving
stuff I don't know oh but keep it
anonymous to your toasters at gmail.com
this has been a wonderful episode of the
morning toast thank you guys so much for
being here if you don't know about the
morning shows it's a millennial Morning
Show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube feel
free to give this video a thumbs up
subscribe like comment the whole shebang
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
iTunes Spotify stitcher all the places
leave a review there five stars were so
amazing beautiful skinny and smart we
love you guys and we'll see you tomorrow
with Becca Tobit by tomorrow
you